[موسيقى]
ام
اهلا بكم طلبت ليبيا من الولايات المتحده
توضيح بشان ما سمته عمليه اختطاف ل ابي
انس الليبي على يد القوات الامريكيه من
قلب العاصمه طرابلس وترحيله الى الخارج
الاتهام بالانتماء الى القاعده نتوقف بعد
الخبر لنناقشه من زاويتين
الخط الفاصل بين سياده الدوله الليبيه على
اراضيها وحق امريكا في الدفاع عن امنها
القومي
وهل من تداعيات محتمله لهذه القضيه على
العلاقات الامريكيه الليبيه في المرحله
المقبله
[موسيقى]
قال البنتاغون ان وحده عسكريه امريكيه
اعتقلت ابو انس الليبي من امام بيته في
العاصمه الليبيه طرابلس بتهمه الضلوع في
التفجيرين اللذين استهدفا السفارتين
الامريكيتين في كينيا وتنزانيا عام الف
وتسعمائه وثمانيه وتسعين الحكومه الليبيه
اكدت انها لم تكن على علم مسبق بالحادث
ووصفت عمليه التوقيف بال اختطاف هذه
العمليه تزامنت مع عمليه اخرى قام بها
الجيش الامريكي في الصومال ضد متهمين
بالانتماء للقاعده
ابو انس الليبي القيادي في تنظيم القاعده
واسمه الحقيقي نزيه عبد الحميد الرقيعي
اخيرا في قبضه السلطه الامريكيه الرجل من
اكثر المطلوبين للقبض عليهم احياء اوامره
في قائمه الارهاب التي وضعتها واشنطن
البحث المستمر منذ الفين عن ابي انس
الليبي انتهى بخطفه من منزله في العاصمه
طرابلس تروي زوجته تفاصيل العمليه بعد
صلاه الفجر كان هو راجع للبيت من الصلاه
فكانوا سيارات وقف ينتظروا فيه فلما شفت
من الشباب كانت في سياره
مرسيدس بيضاء فيتو وسياره ثانيه بيضاء
ونزلوا منها رجال ملثمين كانت ملامحهم
طبعا الليبيه كلها وكان العدد الكبير اللي
بنقدر
يعني ممكن يكونوا عشره ممكن حتى اكثر من
عشره العدد وكانوا طبعا كلهم معهم
وكانت مسدسات بالكاتب يقولوا لها اركب
تتهم واشنطن الليبي بالضلوع في التفجيرات
التي استهدفت سفارتي الولايات المتحده في
كينيا وتنزانيا كان ذلك قبل خمسه عشر عاما
وقتل خلال الهجومين اكثر من مائتين وخمسين
شخصا في حينها ان الهجوم ان كان ردا على
التدخل الامريكي في الصومال القبض على
الليبي البالغ من العمر تسعه واربعين عاما
تزامن مع عمليه اخرى للقوات الامريكيه
الخاصه في الصومال استهدفت العمليه منزل
قيادي في تنظيم حركه الشباب بمدينه باراوي
الساحليه وتضاربت الانباء بشان تقييم
نجاحها فضل وزير الخارجيه الامريكي جون
كيري التعليق على ما تعتبره بلاده نجاحا
في مكافحه ما يسمى الارهاب
نتمنى ان يوضح ذلك ان الولايات المتحده لن
تتوقف ابدا عن ملاحقه المسؤولين عن
الاعمال الارهابيه بامكان عناصر القاعده
والمنظمات الارهابيه الاخرى ان يوفروا
لكنهم لم يكونوا في ما من
دون شك ان تكون الاهداف الغربيه في ليبيا
بعد الان في مامن من اي عمليه انتقاميه
وليس ذلك ببعيد في بلد امنه هش لاسباب عده
سرعت السلطات الرسميه الليبيه الى استبعاد
اي روايه تؤكد تعاونها مع الامريكيين من
اجل القبض على الليبي ذكر بيان مكتب رئيس
الوزراء علي زيدان ان الحكومه الليبيه طلب
توضيحات من السلطات الامريكيه بهذا الشان
واضاف البيان ان اي مواطن ليبي يجب ان
يحاكم في بلده بغض النظر عن التهم الموجهه
اليه ولكن الطرابلس اعربت في المقابل عن
املها ان لا يؤثر الحادث على علاقتها
الاستراتيجيه مع واشنطن انا لحكومه عن
الزيدان لن يكون سهل المنال في بلد يفتقد
الى الاستقرار و سلطه الدوله الكامله على
كل السلاح والمناطق والمواطنين
معنا في هذه الحلقه من طرابلس الناشط
الحقوق الليبي خالد ترجمان ومن العاصمه
الامريكيه واشنطن السفير
جيمس جيفري نائب مستشار الامن القومي
الامريكي السابق اهلا بضيفينا لو بدانا
بالسيد جيفري في في واشنطن
اه اه هل كان من حق الولايات المتحده ان
تفعل ما فعلت في ليبيا
اعتقد ان لديها الحلقه وذلك بالتاكيد
تشكيلا يتعلق بالسياده الوطنيه لليبيا
وكذلك بشان طريقه تعاملنا مع الحكومه
الليبيه وما اذا كانت هناك اتصالات وهو ما
نفته الحكومه الليبيه لكن في بعض الاحيان
هناك اتفاقات اقول بين الطرفين يجب
الاكتفاء سر هذه العمليه ولكن في مثل هذه
الظروف وحيد هو ان لدينا اعداد اه ضد
امريكيين هاجموها في بعض البلدان في مثل
هذه الحاله شاهدت من العمليات ضد هؤلاء في
اليمن وفي باكستان وفي اماكن اخرى
وهذه العمليات التي ت اعاده بقبول يعني
سيد جيفري كان بالامكان ان تجد واشنطن
صيغه معينه مع الليبيين
القبض على ابو انس الليبي
ان الخيارات الاولى عندما نتعامل مع
الحكومات الصديقه وفي هذه الحاله نحن
نتعامل مع حكومه صديقه هي
ان السلطات المحليه تقوم بالقاء القبض على
الشخصيات المطلوبين دوليا وتحديدا بامريكا
لكن عندما يكون هناك واضع ليست هناك سيطره
قويه لدى الحكومه على بلدها وقتها الاوضاع
اكثر صعوبه نحن حسب القانون الدولي نحن
نقف مخ دعوه دور المسؤوله عن المسؤوليه
ذلك ما فعلناه في اه افغانستان
لكن الحكومه الليبيه مثل الحكومه اليمنيه
والباكستانيه الدول الصديقه لكنها لا
تسيطر على اراضيها بشكل انتهى وبالتالي
مهمه بالنسبه لامريكا ان تتعقب وناس
يقومون ب هجمات ضدها وضد مصالحها اه سيد
خالد ترجمان هذا المنطق الامريكي في تفسير
ما جرى كيف ينظر اليه في ليبيا
طبعا هذا المنطق من وجهه النظر الامريكيه
كما ذكر السيد جيفري انما من وجهه النظر
الليبيه نحن نعتقد ان ما حدث هو انتهاك
صارخ لسياده ليبيا هو انتهاك لامنها
وانتهاك لهذا الامن
الهش هذا الامن الذي اه نحن باعتراف
حكومتنا غير قادرين على السيطره عليه وغير
قادرين على تامين هذه الدول وفي مقدمتها
امريكا التي قدمت لنا يد العون للاطاحه
بالقذافي وهي تريد ان تقدم لنا يد العون
للسيطره على امننا كيف يحق لها ان تمنح
نفسها كل الحق في انتهاك هذه السياده التي
تحاول عن تبنيها التي تسعى
ومن خلال الامم المتحده ومن خلال اتفاقات
ها معنا ومن خلال تدريبها للجيش وللشرطه
الليبيه ومساعدات هي التقنيه لنا ان اه
تدعمنا للسيطره على هذا الامر كيف تسمح
لنفسها ان تكون هي اول من يخترق هذا الامن
وان تلقي القبض على انسان اه
اه من اه في بيته
وربما لديها اه ضد هذا الشخص ما لديها من
اه مشاكل من اه اتهامات من
اشكالات قد وقعت اه في دول اخرى ولكن هذا
المواطن المواطن الليبي ويقع في ال اه وهو
موجود في الاراضي الليبيه وتحت يفترض ان
يكون تحت سيطره الدوله الليبيه وكان من
الممكن التعامل وفق ال اه البروتوكولات
الدوليه وفق ما تنصحنا به الامم المتحده
وما ينصحنا به الاصدقاء من السعي لاسترداد
الذين انتهكوا حقوقنا في ليبيا وهم اه
موجودين في دول اوروبيه ودول عربيه وصادر
اشارات حمراء ولكن لم يسلموا الى ليبيا اس
الولايات المتحده رات ان تقتص بنفسها وان
اه تاخذ حقها بيدها غير عابئه بما
سيحدث اه في ليبيا او اه تداعيات مثل هذه
العمليه على الامن القومي الليبي
موضوع التداعيات سيترجم ان بعد اذنك موضوع
تداعيات سنعود اليه بعد الفاصل في العلاقه
بين طرابلس وواشنطن على كل اه اه اه ابن
اه ابو انس الليبي عبد الله وهو نجله
بالطبع قال ان والده تواصل مع الحكومه
الليبيه في وقت سابق وابدى لهم عدم
امتناعه او عدم معارضته للمثول امام
القضاء الليبي في اي تهم قد توجه اليها
تم التواصل مع الحكومه الليبيه عن طريق
الوالد انه يعني يتم محاكمته فى الاراضى
الليبيه وعن طريق القضاء الليبي يعني لا
يتم محكمه الخارج وطنه وارضها يعني ما
عنديش ما يعني يحاكم في ارضها ويحاكم يعني
عن القضاء الليبيه وطبعا التقيت في احدى
المرات احد الاجانب في معسكرات في معسكرات
اه يعني انا نعرف من الوالد في ليبيا نريد
يعني تحدث معاه استجوابه مثلا يعني مش
مشكله عاديه يمكن الاستجواب
محاكمته لكن في ليبيا وعن طريق القضاء
الليبي يعني لا يتم اخراجها منه
سيد جيمس جيفري بعد ما تابعنا ما قاله اه
اه ابن ابو انس ليبي لماذا تعذر اه الوصول
الى هذه المحاكمه طوال عامين تقريبا هو من
تاريخ عودته الى ليبيا
نحن لا نعرف تفاصيل هذا الامر ونحن نود
حصول تاكيد على امرين بشكل واضح اولهما هو
ان ابو سليم ي لم يكن تابعا وانما كان
موجودا في طرابلس وليس وكان موجودا في
منطقه سكنيه الامر الثاني هو ان هناك
اتهامات دوليه كثيره ضده وليست اتهامات
امريكيه حصريا وبالتالي الموضوع المات
الامام لا والذي ليست اجوبه حيال ه هو اه
ما هي الاتصالات التي جرت بين الحكومه
الامريكيه والامم المتحده ودول اخرى اه
والحكومه الليبيه قبل هذه العمليه كان
يوجد وان واعتقل
وانتظر عمليه المحاكمه او تسليمه الى
امريكا وهو ما لم يحدث اذن علينا ان دورا
في المائه اذا كانت خلفيه لهذا الامر وما
اذا كانت هناك اتصالات بين امريكا
والحكومه الليبيه بشان مصير هذا الشخص و و
ابو انس الليبي سيدخل الترجمان اه عاد الى
ليبيا ابان الثوره اه بمعنى انه على الاقل
لديه سنتين الان في ليبيا برايك لماذا
عجزت الحكومه الليبيه على التعاطي مع هذا
الموضوع قبل ان تصل الامور الى هذا الحد
وهو عمليه الاختطاف كما وصفت
هذا سؤالا هاما وخاصه ان ابنه الان قد صرح
بان والده قد ابدى استعداده للمثول امام
القضاء ليبي واه للتحقيق معه اه في ليبيا
فانا اعتقد ان السبب الاساسي هو ضعف
الحكومه الليبيه هو عدم قدرتها على بسط
امنها وسيطرتها واه عدم قدرتها على
التعاطي مع مطالب هذا الشخص السيد انس اه
اقر وطالبان يحاكم في ليبيا وطالبان يسلم
نفسه الحكومه الليبيه وان يمثل امام
القضاء الليبي حسب ما ورد في تصريحات ابنه
وهذا اه لم تستطع ليبيا ان تتعامل معها
انا اعتقد ان اه الحكومه الليبيه عندما
نظرت الى هذا الامر اه اعتقد ان خاصه ان
تتعاطى مع هذا امر في ظل هذه الوضعيه
الامنيه المترديه الليبيه ولكن ولكن هل
واشنطن السيد جيمس جيفري هل واشنطن طلبت
تسلم ابو انس الليبي من الحكومه الليبيه
في مثل هذه الحاله تحديدا لا يمكن ان اؤكد
هذا الامر على يتعين علينا ان نستمع الى
بيانات من الحكومتين بهذا الشان ما نعرفه
هو انه في حالات اخرى مثل الحاله
الافغانيه في الفين وواحد في وتحديد ما
يتعلق باسامه بن لادن وفي حاله باكستان
نحن عاده ما نطلبه من الحكومات ان تسلم
الاشخاص ما يلي نقدم لها الوثائق الضروريه
عندما لا يتم اعتقال هؤلاء الاشخاص وعندما
لا يسوع بما يسمح لهؤلاء بان احرارا فنحن
وقتها نعتقد اننا سنقوم تخطيطي
اتخاذ قرار بشان اه سيد جيفري ايضا هناك
نقطه مهمه ابو انس الليبي عام الفين تحصل
على اللجوء السياسي في
بريطانيا ومنها بعد ذلك ذهب الى باكستان
كيف نفهم ان حكومه حليفه للولايات المتحده
وهي بريطانيا تمنحه اللجوء مع انه قبل
سنتين كان يفترض ان يكون متهم بما تتهمه
به واشنطن الان
هذا سؤال جيد وشيء على ان تحري تفاصيل
الموضوع والسؤال المهم هو متى كانت
الاتهامات التي قدمت له
ما نعرفه بعد اه الف وتسعمائه وتسعه
وثمانين السؤال كان هو من هو المسؤول عن
تفجيرات في كينيا وتنزانيا
لكن ل متاكده انه عندما عرفنا التفاصيل
فان انتخبنا الخطوات الدوليه الضروريه في
القبض عليه وان يتم تقديمه الى نابلس
محاكمه السيد ترجمان طرابلس طلبه توضيحات
من الولايات المتحده في هذا الموضوع ما
تتوقع ان تكون هذه التوضيحات
لا ادري اه موقف الولايات المتحده من
ابداء التوضيحات التي طلبتها ليبيا ولكن
البيان الليبي الخجول الذي صدر اه حقيقه
اه لا لا يعبر عن ما يجب ان يعبر عنه اه
بحكم انه فقط طالب اه توضيحات وكذلك شدد
على اهميه العلاقات مع امريكا ولم يتطرق
اطلاقا لاختراق السياده واه للسياده
الليبيه وما اه
مات بع هذه هذه العمليه من اعتداء على
سياده دوله دون الاخذ في اعتبار وضعها
الامني و هشاشته ال ال الحكومه الليبيه اه
اعتبرت بانها بلغت حسب اه مسؤول امريكي في
اه اه شبكه سين انقال انها بلغت هل تتوقع
ان فعلا طرابلس بلغت وهي الان محرجه
اه بمثل هذا البيان الذي صدر يجب ان اه
اه تقوم العمليه الحكومه الليبيه خطوه
شجاعه
وان تعلن انك انت تعلم بهذا الامر
ووافقت على اه القيام بهذه العمليه او ان
هذا الامر قد حدث رغم ارادتها ونعلم ان
هناك امور كثيره تحدث رغم اراده الحكومه
الليبيه ولكن على الحكومه الان ان توضح في
بيان واضح وصريح للشعب الليبي انك انت
تعلم بهذه العمليه ووافقت على اختراق
سيادتها بهذا الشكل ام لا نحن ننتظر بيان
اكثر شموليه واكثر وضوح و اكثر شفافيه من
الحكومه الليبيه اه على كل بعد الفاصل
سنحاول التطرق الى اه التداعيات المحتمله
للعلاقات الامريكيه على العلاقات
الامريكيه اه الليبيه جراء هذا الحادث لنا
عوده بعد فاصل نرجو ان تبقوا معنا
[موسيقى]
ام
اهلا بكم من جديد ما زلتم معنا في هذه
الحلقه التي نتناول فيها موضوع قيام
الولايات المتحده بالقبض على ابي انس
الليبي من طرابلس بتهمه الانتماء اه
للقاعده اه سيد جيمس جيفري في واشنطن
الحكومه الليبيه في بيان لها اعتبرت بان
الشراكه الاستراتيجيه بين ليبيا والولايات
المتحده تتعرض لمخاطر جراء ما حدث هل هناك
نفس الانطباع في واشنطن
اعتقد بان امريكا ستكون حاضره بهذا الخصوص
لكن مجددا نحن لدينا تجربه كبيره مع اليمن
وباكستان ومع دول اخرى فنحن في بعض
الاحيان تتخذ اعمال والاجراءات اه
تستقر الدول السعيد بها سعيده بذلك التي
تعبر عنها بشكل علني وفي بعض الاحيان تكون
الدول لا تحبها وفي بعض الاحيان نقوم
باعمال تثير مشاكل بالنسبه لل دوليا
المعنيه وفي هذه الحاله اعتقد ان الامر
انما يتعلق بالحاله الاولى والثانيه فنحن
تربطنا علاقات جيده مع ليبيا ونرى الكثير
في محاولتنا في اه القضاء على في القضاء
على الارهابيين في هذه الاماكن التي لا
تسيطر عليها الحكم في الاماكن التي يتحرك
فيها هناك الذين هاجموا اه سفارتنا وهذا
مهم بالنسبه لنا وكما قالت الحكومه
للضيافه نحن شركاء استراتيجيين في بحثا عن
هؤلاء الارهابيين والتنكيل بيوم الاستيطان
ت على ارض منها هذا مهم بالنسبه لنا اه
على ذكر الهجوم على السفاره
مصرع السفير الا تخشى واشنطن الان ان تغذي
مشاعر الكراهيه ضد الولايات المتحده جراء
ما حدث لا بس اه الشاب اه ال الليبي عفوا
لكنني اعتقد ان
هناك معاداه لامريكا دائما في جميع انحاء
العالم وعاده من ما يستخدم الناس الفعل
التي نقوم بها ك تعلل ذلك وليس هناك اي
تبرير
مهاجمه المؤسسات الدبلوماسيه الامريكيه
كما حدث في بنغازي وفي نيروبي وكما حدث
ايضا في دار السلام ليس هناك اي تبرير
الاطلاق بقتل مئات الاشخاص كما حدث في
نايروبي وحتى تتوقف ها مثلا فعال في
امريكا ستقوم باعمال بما فيها تلك التي
حدثت اه في ليبيا يسرقون بها عبر العالم
وهذا واقع الحال هو ال ال ال لتصحيح
الهجوم كان بالطبع على القنصليه الامريكيه
في بنغازي وليس على السفاره السيد خالد
الترجمان هل هناك امكانيه اه اه ان تتحول
اه بعض ردود الفعل لدى الليبيين الى اعمال
انتقاميه كما فهم على الاقل من بعض
التصريحات الوارده في وكاله الانباء
اه هذا الامر اه قد يكون اه محتمل اه
الحدود
وخاصه ان اه كما يعلم الجميع ان وضعنا
الامني اه
واه غير قادره السلطات الليبيه على التحكم
في اه الكثير من الامور اه الامنيه اه
ولكن اه بشكل او اخر انا اعتقد ان اه
الامور لابد ان تو ان ان تكون واضحا من
الحكومه الليبيه وهذا مايو اما اه اريد ان
نركز عليه ان الحكومه الليبيه عليها ان
تعلمنا نحن الليبيون لماذا حدث ما حدث
لماذا سمحت ان كانت على علم ب اه اه
اختراق سيادتها واه بالتدخل في شاننا بهذا
الشكل اه المزعج او ان لم تكن اه طرفا في
هذه العمليه عليها ان تقول ذلك بوضوح
وصراحه وعليها ان تطلب من الولايات
المتحده ليس فقط تبرير ما حدث ولكن
الاعتذار عن
اه هذا ال اه التدخل في السياده الوطنيه
الليبيه لان هذا الامر اه اه امر بهذا
الشكل سيعطي مبرر بعد ذلك للجميع للتدخل
من اجل حمايه مصالحهم ومن اجل اه مطارده
اه مشبوهين او المطلوبين لديها وهذا سيفتح
الباب على مصرعيه لكل دول العالم ان تتدخل
في شانها كيف مشات وقت ما شاءت اه باي حجه
كان حتى بعيدا عن قرارات الامم المتحده اه
تسعطاشر اربعه وسبعين البند السابع منه او
تسعه وعشرين خمسين اه اه تستطيع هذه الدول
ان تبرر لنفسها اي عمليات مستقبليه اتجاه
ليبيا وهذا ما انا اركز عليه بالفعل اما
اه ردود الافعال فهذه تحدث في كافه
المناطق حتى احيانا لا تكون امريكا قد
اتخذت فيها فعل اه ضد هذه الشعوب او ضد
هذه المناطق او ضد هذه الدول فما بالك في
دوله قد يحدث فيها ما حدث اه الذين في
ليبيا فتعلم بالتاكيد الولايات المتحده
خلفيه تمام يمكن ان يحدث عندما تقوم بمثل
هذه العمليه ال الان سيد اه جفري هل تعتقد
بان من مصلحه واشنطن وطرابلس الان ان
يسارع الى احتواء ايه تداعيات
مزعجه اه في المستقبل
بالتاكيد في مصلحه البلدين والسيد
الترجمان محق في هذا الامر الامر معقد وهو
مثل احراج للحكومه بالاخص فيما قد تعرفه
بشانها وقد لا تعرفه وبالتاكيد يجب ان
تتصرف حيال هذا الكلام لكن كما قال
الترجمه وباعتبار الوضع الامني الهش داخل
ليبيا فهناك مجالات لا تتصرف تستطيع
الحكومه ان تتصرف فيه وفي ظل هذه الظروف
اذا شعرنا نحو الامريكيين بالتهديد من
خلال عدم مقدره حكم الجبير تصرف نحن لدينا
مسؤوليه ل امام شعبنا من الابرياء الذين
يقتلون بشكل مستمر عبر العالم من خلال
مجموعات اه ابو انس عضو فيها نحن مسؤولون
ا لا تصرف لوحدنا نحن نفضل ان نتصرف من
خلال الحكومه الامريكيه اه المصريه
الليبيه لكنها لم تحقق ذلك كل سنه صرف
لوحدنا ولا ولكن سيد جيفري هل هذا ممكن في
ظل اه تصريحات من وزير الخارجيه كيري ومن
وزير الدفاع بان واشنطن لن تتوقف عن
ملاحقه هؤلاء المطلوبين في اي مكان في
العالم
بالتاكيد الى تعاقب هؤلاء اه هو الاجراء
يتعلق بالاستخبارات اننا سنحاول مكان
احتفالهم اذا كانوا في باريس لا اعتقد
اننا سنقوم بعمليات القبض عليهم وانما
سنتحدث للمسؤولين الفرنسيه واما اذا كانوا
في اماكن في باكستان مثل مثلا في كراتشي
في نفس الشيء
اليه ما اذا كانوا في اماكن في مالي او
الصومال او اليمن حيث وجدوا سيطره الحكومه
عليهم او
عمليه البحث عنهم ستؤدي الى مشاكل سياسيه
وعمليه الكبيره وقتها سنتصرف اللواء
لوحدنا الامر يتعلق بالظروف ان عمليه
التعقب في نهايه المطاف هي تتمثل في
استخدام كافه القوات الوطنيه بما فيها
لابعاد الاستخباراتيه والقانونيه وفي بعض
الاحيان هناك استخدام الجوانب الاقتصاديه
والعسكريه شكرا جزيلا لك السفير جيفري
النائب مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي
السابق شكرا ايضا لضيفنا
من طرابلس الناشط الحقوقي الليبي خالد
ترجمان بهذا مشاهدينا الكرام نكون قد
وصلنا الى نهايه هذه الحلقه غدا باذن الله
قراءه جديده في ما وراء خبر الجديد
استودعكم الله
ام
[موسيقى]